السيد أوموت مرحبًا بكم مرة أخرى في البرنامج،
أتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكاني المتابعة من حيث
توقفت مع جيرسام جورنبيرج، سألته
عن الضرورات المتنافسة على ما يبدو
لإعادة الرهائن
إلى رئيس الوزراء كما تعلم، يفعل
ما تريده العائلات وهذا هو
لحماية الرهائن وفي نفس
الوقت الاقتباس سحق حماس
عسكريا وسياسيا هما
ممكنان في نفس
الوقت
إنه سؤال جيد جدا يا كريستين
ولست متأكدا من
ذلك على شاشة التلفزيون لأنني أعتقد أنها
طريقة حساسة للغاية فمن الممكن أه  للقيام
بهذا وذاك في نفس الوقت أه
سيتعين على الحكومة اتخاذ قرار
وأه أعتقد أن هذا أه أه
أود أن أقول قرار تشيلي ماذا
نفعل أه أولاً هل أه نركز على أه
الإخلاء والإفراج عن
الرهائن أم نستمر في
هجوم عسكري كامل أه ضد حماس وهل
يمكن أن يكون
بطريقة أو بأخرى أه مجتمعين أه ماذا ستفعل
كرئيس للوزراء ماذا ستفعل أشك في ذلك أشك في ذلك أشك في
ماذا
ستفعل أشك في ذلك
ستفعل عندما أصبح رئيسًا للوزراء سأخبرك
بشيء واحد يمكنني أن أخبرك به عندما كنت
رئيسًا للوزراء اعتقدت أن أه
الصفقة التي عقدناها بشأن آه آه والتي
تم عرضها علينا آه لإطلاق سراح واحد  أه
سجين أه كان غير مقبول على الإطلاق وقد
رفضته الآن لدينا
238 واحد أه تم إطلاق سراحهم الليلة الماضية في
عملية بطولية أم عسكرية
لجهاز المخابرات لدينا وهو أه
مشجع للغاية ولكن لا يزال لدينا
238 رهينة ولا أعتقد أن
حماس  جاهز أو سيكون جاهزًا لإطلاق
سراحهم في صفقة سريعة،
سيستغرق الأمر الكثير من الوقت لإطلاق سراحهم،
لذا إذا كان شرط إطلاق سراحهم
هو إنهاء الهجوم العسكري،
فعلينا عمليًا أن نتخلى عن
الهجوم العسكري لشيء ما
أه مشكوك فيه وربما
مستحيل لأنني لا أعتقد أن
حماس ستطلق سراحهم دفعة واحدة
ثم سيمددونها
لفترة طويلة مما سيجعل أه
العملية العسكرية عفا عليها الزمن فأه
السؤال ما هي الاستراتيجية أم  أه
مصلحة دولة إسرائيل وأه
هذا سؤال صعب للغاية للإجابة عليه
في هذه المرحلة يا إلهي، أقصد أن
أسمعك كما تعلم سؤال
لا يصدق لأن هذا هو بالضبط ما
يتلخص كل هذا في ما هي
المصلحة وكيف  لتحقيق ذلك، ولكن في
هذه الأثناء، حتى أقرب
أصدقاء إسرائيل، الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
يشعرون بالانزعاج أكثر فأكثر، ومن الناحية
السياسية فإن الرئيس ووزير
الخارجية ومستشار الأمن القومي
جميعهم يطلبون من إسرائيل أن
تعتني بالمدنيين الذين سمعناهم.
وسنقوم بتشغيل مقابلته بعد أن نتحدث
إليكم، لا يوجد مكان آمن في غزة، ولا يوجد أي
من هؤلاء المدنيين سواء كانوا
يستمعون إلى الطلب أو
التحذير بالتحرك من الشمال إلى الجنوب،
لا يوجد مكان آمن، كل شيء يتعرض
للقصف  8000 قتيل العديد منهم
أطفال ولا يُسمح
بدخول المساعدات، أعتقد أنني أريد فقط أن أسألك
كرئيس للوزراء، هل كنت
ستفرض حصارًا كاملاً ولا
مساعدات إنسانية وحتى قصف ما يسمى
بالمناطق الآمنة المسيحية؟  ينبغي
التأكيد عليه رقم واحد مع كامل
احترامي للأرقام التي تقتبسها أه
الأرقام لم يتم التحقق منها وهي
مطلقة مضخمة عن أي
أبعاد واقعية عن القتلى
والجرحى أه وهذا جزء من أه
دعاية حماس التي يجب
يؤخذ مع قليل من الملح، حسنًا ومع
كل احترامك، لا أستطيع قبول ذلك
وأقترح عليك أن تكون حذرًا للغاية عندما تفعل ذلك،
دعني أطلب منك هذا على
وجه التحديد وأطلب منك هذا على وجه التحديد يا
رئيس الوزراء لأن كل المتحدث باسم جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي الخاص بك
ويقول الناس كيف يمكنك أن
تأخذ أرقام حماس أولاً وقبل كل شيء، لقد
تحققنا منها مع الأمم المتحدة ومنظمة الصحة العالمية، ويقولون
لنا في
الماضي، إن الدورات الخمس الست للصراع، كانت
هذه الأرقام التي تديرها وزارة الصحة في غزة، والتي تديرها حماس،
تعتبر ذات مصداقية
أيضًا.  هل هذا ما تفعله منظمة الصحة العالمية ولكني لن
أفهم، لن أعلمك أنك
مقيد في معركة أرقام معك،
إنه أمر فظيع ويتم
قصف المدنيين، كيف يساعد ذلك في
مجهودك الحربي، دعني أه أحاول و  قم بالرد أولا بكل
احترام، أرقام الأمم المتحدة
ذات مصداقية مثل أرقام حماس
ونترك الأمر جانبا لثانية حسنا،
أنا لا أثق في أرقام الأمم المتحدة، أرقام الأمم المتحدة
ليست موثوقة للغاية، لقد قُتل 50 من
أفرادها
أخبرنا في الواقع 60 الآن
63 من أهلهم أنا نادم أنا
نادم على وفاة صدقني أنا نادم على
وفاة الجميع وأنا
آسف جدا لذلك ولكن أه هذا لا يعني
أن هناك تقارير عن عدد من
الضحايا و  عدد الضحايا
دقيق بالضرورة ولكن
السؤال الأهم هو ما المتوقع
من إسرائيل أن تفعله عندما كان الرئيس بايدن
في إسرائيل والرئيس بايدن
صديق وليس لدي شك في
التزامه التام والتزامه الأخلاقي
والتزامه بأمن إسرائيل.  دولة
إسرائيل عندما قال إن لإسرائيل
الحق في الرد ونحن نفهم أن
إسرائيل سترد وستدعمها
ماذا توقع ماذا يمكننا أن نفعل ذلك
لن ينطوي للأسف على
درجة معينة من الأضرار الجانبية التي نريد
تجنب وقوع أكبر عدد ممكن من الضحايا فيها  نستطيع،
وبالمناسبة، أن توافق إسرائيل على إمداد
الفلسطينيين بالإمدادات الإنسانية التي كانت
تنسحب من وسط غزة في
الجنوب، والحقيقة هي أنه في كل يوم هناك
عشرات الشاحنات،
قوافل الشاحنات التي تأتي من
مصر وتقدم المساعدات الإنسانية.  الإمداد والدعم
الإنساني
للفلسطينيين ليس فقط أننا
وافقنا عليه ولكن كان هناك نقاش كبير
داخل
الحكومة الإسرائيلية التي
أعرفها تمامًا ولكن هناك قطرة في
المحيط الذي كنا نراقبه  يا رئيس
الوزراء، لدينا أشخاص على الحدود،
إنها قطرة في محيط، لم يكن لها
معنى بعد، وآمل أن تكون كذلك، ولكن
أعتقد أنني أريد أن أطرح عليك
سؤالاً آخر، لأن حكومتك،
وزير دفاعك، طرحها جميع وزرائك المختلفين
بالضبط ما
يعتقدون أنه حصار كامل على غزة
قالوا إن غزة ستتحول
إلى قطاع مليء بالخيام
قالوا إننا سنزيل جميع
القيود عن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي قالها يوآف جالانت وقالوا
ذلك  هذه الأشياء وأنا
أتساءل كيف
ستنتهي الأمور ولكن ما أريد أن أسألك عنه
بشكل خاص لا لا سيدي رئيس الوزراء
استمع لي أريد أن أعرف ما إذا كنت تعتقد أن
هذا سيجعلك أكثر أمانًا على
المدى الطويل لأن  تظهر أحدث استطلاعات الرأي والتي
تم إجراؤها في غزة قبل
الحرب قبل 7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر) أن
غالبية سكان غزة لا يحبون حماس ويريدون
التحرر من حماس، لذا فإن
هذا العقاب الجماعي، في
رأيك، أين سيضع
الأجيال القادمة كما ستكون حماس؟  في السيطرة
على غزة لن يكون هناك أي تغيير
وسيظلون ضحايا
الفظائع وأه
القبضة الحديدية لحماس ضد
المدنيين في غزة الطريقة الوحيدة لإطلاق
سراح أولئك الذين يعانون من
حماس في غزة هو القضاء على حماس
التي  يعني على إسرائيل مواصلة
عمليتها العسكرية ومحاولة القيام
بذلك بقدر الإمكان وبأقصى قدر من
الحذر من أجل أه تقليل
الأضرار الجانبية إلى أقصى حد
ممكن وهذا ما نحاول
فعله علينا  افعل شيئًا تعرفه
عندما أطلب منك أسألك أه أه كريستين
عندما تقول وأجريت مقابلة معي في
اليوم الأول أنك تفهم أن على
إسرائيل أن ترد بالضبط ما الذي
توقعه أي شخص أن إسرائيل ستفعل هل يمكننا
مهاجمة حماس دون التواصل معها
أين هم وإذا كانوا في
وسط غزة، هل يمكننا أن نفعل شيئًا
ربما لن يخلق أيضًا
بعض الضمانات، ولكن كيف
يمكننا تحرير غزة من حماس إذا
لم نهاجمهم، فسنواصل
متابعة هذا  أهود شكرا
جزيلا لوجودك معنا